"Filthy water cannot be washed," according to a West African proverb.
But what if it could?
That's the goal of a wastewater treatment plant,...
...like the one that serves the Washington area.
The Blue Plains wastewater treatment facility is the largest of its kind in the world.
And according to its Director of Wastewater Treatment Walt Bailey,...
...the plant is a model that other countries may hope to emulate.
We're a very popular tourist stop here.
We've received visitors from all over the world: Asia, Europe, Africa, and South America.
They're looking for sharing of ideas and sharing of technology.
As a matter of fact, Walt says the technology involved in nitrogen removal...
...for wastewater was developed in Cape Town, South Africa.
But what Blue Plains has built may be difficult for many other countries...
...to replicate because of cost.
We've spent probably a billion dollars over the last ten years improving every feature.
But if you wanna come and see any one of the pieces...
...to understand how the primary treatment works,...
...how the secondary treatment works, how the filtering system works,...
...what technology is being used, and the computer systems that we have set up to manage the plant.
Any one of those pieces may be relevant to the systems...
...to the systems that you're putting in your place.
And we welcome people coming here, and learning from what we've done.
Flooding wastewater can have devastating effects on a region's environment.
Crops were recently lost near the Gaza town of Khan Younis...
...because of wastewater that flooded farms before it reached the treatment facility.
In other parts of the world, human and animal waste...
...making its way into a community's water is blamed for a number of deadly diseases.
That is one of the great services that you seek to have in modern society,...
...and without it, there's catastrophe to pay.
For example, more people die every year from waterborne illnesses...
...in the rest of the world than in all the wars...
...because of the tremendous consequence of pollutants in the water waste.